mechanistic materialism which is still  the dominant philosophy in science is  that the universe is unconscious matters  unconscious the only reality is matter  or physical reality and Consciousness is  produced in brains by brain activity  therefore if you benefit from meditation  if you feel a sense of Greater  Consciousness Connection it's all inside  your head is nothing but a change in the  neurotransmitter levels or patterns of  nervous activity in different regions of  the brain it's inside your head but the  reason meditation developed in Hindu  Buddhist cultures and in contemplative  Christianity in monasteries was because  people thought that by getting to the  very ground of Consciousness in our own  minds we connect with the ground of  consciousness of the entire universe  that our minds are part of a much  greater mind they're a kind of fractal  version of the Divine mind which  underlies all reality and all forms of  Consciousness within the universe